how some of the world's famous
hackersical Court ehinyo Ochoa was
sentenced to two years in prison because
of this photo of his girlfriend the
former member of anonymous leaked this
photo to the internet along with a
databases of multiple U.S government
departments so he wanted to make the
government look a fool but he forgot
that the photo contained information
about his geolocation Ross ulbricht
created the largest website for the sale
of Narcotics the hacker was arrested in
a public library the police staged a
fight and Ross was distracted by this
scene he left his computer unattended
not even bothering to minimize his
browser he received a life sentence in
2012 Jeremy Hammond was the FBI's Most
Wanted cyber criminal he hacked and
leaked secret data of the U.S
intelligence service online the police
had no difficulty obtaining evidence of
his crimes because the password on
Jeremy's computer was the name of his
cat shuey123 Jeremy was given a 10-year
prison sentence don't be like Jeremy and
don't use your personal information in
your passwords this is some sub like And
subscribe if you want to learn more
about the online jungle